i never want people to think that i'm
coming out to
change the narrative or to brush over
and not take responsibility for my
actions open to set the record straight
colton tells variety that his coming out
had nothing to do with damage control
last september his ex cassie randolph
filed a restraining order against him
accusing colton of harassing and
stalking her she later had her request
to drop the restraining order granted
were you ever physically abusive in any
way no
never that's not who i am as a person
while i own i made a lot of mistakes i
just
it's hard saying those words but colton
does admit that there was another
motivating factor to come out publicly
blackmail he says after secretly
visiting an la spa
last year known for its gay clientele he
received an anonymous email claiming to
have a nude photo of him
and threatening to out him variety notes
it has reviewed the email
at that point colton says he knew he
needed to have an honest conversation
about his life the whole point of coming
out too is so i can actually have a real
emotional connection with a man and
not have to hide it not to be in the
closet
[Music]
i want a partner and a husband more than
anything and i want
a family